thanks to today's sponsor fast hosts if
you're based in the uk
you have the chance to win the ultimate
tech bundle
including your dream pc setup worth up
to 5 000 pounds
if you can answer my techie test
question that is
link in the description and i'll explain
more later on in the video
hey 42 here people run for all sorts of
different reasons
some are in it for the competition and
the chance to prove they're the fastest
others want to keep fit with one eye on
the track and the other on their
waistline
and still others just want an excuse to
be incessantly smug
and use their athletic feats to make
their friends feel fat and ugly
but some people run for reasons that are
far less fathomable
take the inhabitants of brockworth
a village in gloucester for example who
perhaps thanks to an insatiable appetite
for dairy products
gather yearly to chase a four kilogram
wheel of double gloucester cheese
down a hill so steep that it makes
actual human
running pretty much impossible the first
one to catch the cheese
gets to keep it good as reason as any
for risking both your life
and your dignity i suppose and common
techniques for retaining maximum speed
on the way down
include the sideways roll the bump scoot
also known as the coccyx splitter and
the always popular but
never planned attempts to actually run
before face planting with enough force
to swallow your own teeth
of course that can only be one winner
but the supply of horrific injuries
is unlimited to help make up for that
broken bones from brutal falls are the
most common maimings
but rumor has it the great cheese chase
of 1990
saw a 58 year old granny knocked out
cold
by the cheese itself then there's the
mount everest
treppen marathon that sees competitors
given
24 hours to climb the height
of earth's tallest mountain up a single
set of steps
in saxony germany it's hard to know
exactly why anyone would willingly
inflict this experience on themselves
but i suspect it may come out of a
suppressed desire to achieve the world
record
for the youngest person in history to
undergo knee replacement surgery
those hoping to complete the entire
course
must climb a grand total of 79
400 steps during the 24-hour period
in sankayavi finland some young men
run out of a sense of nostalgia
for the good old days when finding
yourself a wife was as simple as
jogging off to a nearby village grabbing
the prettiest girl you could find and
sprinting back home
with her flung over one shoulder in the
modern day version of this event
known quite fittingly as wife carrying
male competitors carry their female
teammates
over a 252 meter obstacle course
with the winners the first couple to
cross the line
popular carrying methods include the
classic piggyback
the time-honored fireman's carry and
the intriguingly named estonian style
which is a bit like the piggyback but
upside down
distinctly unhygienic if you ask me and
then there's the sri chinmoy
self-transcendent race named for the
indian spiritual leader who founded it
back in 1996
which might just be the weirdest and the
most extreme race
held anywhere on planet earth
tree chimney was born in chittagong
district in what was at the time
british india but is today part of
bangladesh though he spent most of his
adulthood in the u.s
during his lifetime he amassed some 7
000 students
across 60 different countries and when
he wasn't busy being
all spiritual and that he was a prolific
author
an avid painter and he played the flute
but what he was most famous for
bizarrely enough is lifting people up
and no i'm not speaking metaphorically
here
he specialized in literally picking
people up off the floor
during his prolific human hefting career
mr chimnoy is said to have had a go at
hoisting
nelson mandela desmond tutu muhammad ali
sting eddie murphy susan sarandon
roberta flack yoko ono jeff goldblum
richard gere helen hunt billie jean king
a group of 20 nobel laureates
a team of sumo wrestlers and the entire
ac
milan football team you have to hand it
to him
the guy has a hell of a lot of a-lift
celebrities on his cv
the reason for this frankly bizarre
spate of human hoistings
to show his appreciation for the
achievements of the people he
lifted apparently something to think
about the next time you meet someone you
respect
in all sri chimney is thought to have
lifted
over 7 000 people in his lifetime
but doing anything 7 000 times is bound
to get annoying
which is probably why sri like to keep
things fresh
by lifting things besides human beings
including a helicopter
a car an aeroplane and even an elephant
you may not be able to lift an elephant
but you can win a computer
if you're based in the uk and you're
looking to start a blog or maybe launch
your business
then fast hosts is the place to go
regardless of your experience
fast host provides all the web hosting
products services
and tools you need to bring your project
to life
and establish your web presence fast
host's powerful and reliable hosting
offers smart ssd storage and unlimited
bandwidth
in uk data centers with 24 7 specialist
support on hand
you'll never have to worry about server
outages again
i get through mountains of data every
week creating these videos
but it's important to me that i never
lose any of it
i'd recommend fast host cloud backup to
seamlessly backup your data
and should the worst happen you can
recover it
in minutes test it out by getting five
gigabytes of cloud backup
absolutely free uk viewers have the
chance to win the ultimate
tech bundle including your dream pc
setup
worth up to five thousand pounds if you
can answer my techy test
question they asked me to write as of
what's the name of the world's longest
fiber optic
cable visit the link in the description
to answer my question
and enter the competition today more
than anything sri chimnoy was a firm
believer
in the power of athletics as an aide to
spiritualism
and it was this that led to the
development
of the self-transcendence race but
just what is so special about it well
let's start with the most obvious bit
the sri chinmoy self transcendence race
is the longest foot race run anywhere in
the world
just how long well to most people your
everyday bog standard marathon
is the benchmark of a lung grace i mean
the word
marathon literally means long
right but sri chimney was a man who
lifted
elephants up just for the hell of it he
laughed in the face of marathons
the first time the self-transcendence
race was run in 1996 the course was
those of you with asthma might want to
grab an inhaler and find a nice
comfortable spot to sit down
two thousand seven hundred miles long
at the inaugural event the male
competition was won
by latvian george germaladjevs
and no female athlete managed to
complete the course
mr chimnoy was unperturbed during the
medal ceremony for the event he
apparently decided
that george didn't look quite close
enough to death
for his liking so he got hold of a
microphone
looked his champ squarely in the eyes
and announced that next year's course
would be 3 100 miles long
the self-transcendence race has been
competed over that distance
ever since now 3
100 miles is a pretty long way
for context the distance between the
most northerly point of the uk
jonah gropes and the most sovereignly
point lands end
is a measly 603 miles in a straight line
or around 874 miles if you travel by
road
which means that if the
self-transcendent rate was run
in the uk athletes would have to run the
equivalent
of the entire length of the kingdom
around 3.5
times in order to reach the finish line
the distance is quite frankly absurd
in 2017 the legendary le mans 24 hours
race
was won by timo bernhard brendan hartley
and earl bamber
during the race the team completed 367
laps of the track
and covered 3107 miles
exactly seven miles further than
competitors run
in the street chimney cell transcendent
race impressive stuff
but of course they were driving a car
and not just any car a 900 horsepower
porsche 919 hybrid
with a top speed of over 200 miles per
hour runners in the self-transcendence
race
cover this outrageous distance alone
and entirely under their own steam and
whilst they do have rather more than 24
hours to complete the course
they don't have as much time as you
might think for a foot race covering
more than 3 000
miles the course is open between 6 am
and midnight for a grand total of 52
days
that's 7.5 weeks to run the distance
between london
and moscow twice to see just how
ridiculous this race
really is let's do some quick maths in
order to complete the entire course
within the allotted time
of 52 days participants have to run a
minimum of 59.62 miles
per day most people train months on ends
to run
a single marathon but to finish the
street in my self-transcendence race you
have to get yourself in good enough
shape
to run comfortably more than two
marathons a day
for 52 consecutive days and remember
that's
the minimum requirement to scrape home
on the final day of the race like some
kind of
unfit bum if you actually want to stand
a chance of winning this thing
you're going to have to set your sights
a little higher the current course
record was achieved by asperhanol
alto a finn who crossed the finish line
in 40 days 9 hours 6 minutes
and 21 seconds that's the equivalent
of 76.78 miles per day
or just short of three full marathons
every day
for 40 days straight in order to cover
such a mind-boggling distance
most participants sleep a maximum of
five hours a night
and have to eat around 10 000 calories
in an attempt to maintain their body
weight wondering how you might go about
taking in 10
000 calories when you're spending every
waking second running
ultrarunning legend william sichul from
scotland
who completed the race in 2014 overcame
this calorific
challenge by chugging ice cream
three liters of the stuff per day
pre-melted
for ease of swallowing the event even
takes a toll on the wardrobe
with some runners getting through as
many as 20 pairs of shoes during the
course of the race
and most runners will require at least
one haircut
mid-race considering all of this
hardship
it is perhaps no surprise that in the 23
years the race has been held
at the full distance of 3 100 miles
just 44 different people
have managed to actually finish it
within the allotted time
now the elephant in the room here or
should that be the elephant perched
precariously
on tree chimney's shoulders right next
to the ghost of nelson mandela
is the fact that i failed to mention one
apparently key element of this bizarre
event
the location in which it's held
you're probably thinking that the one
plus side to this
near endless running madness is the
chance to take in some
incredible scenery along the way after
all if you're running 3100 miles
you're almost certainly covering a wide
variety of spectacular terrain
mountains valleys forests beaches
and spanning multiple countries probably
even an entire continent
well not quite the street chimney self
race is actually run in just
one place jamaica
now you may well be thinking that isn't
so bad
jamaica is a lovely country after all
and there's no doubt plenty
to see there sure a small caribbean
island just 150 miles across
seems like a slightly odd choice for a 3
100 mile race but at least you'll get to
know it pretty well
over the course of your 52 days but
no because the self-transcendence race
does not in fact take place on the
caribbean island
of jamaica every single mile of it
is instead run in the neighborhood
of jamaica in the borough of queens
new york in fact the entire course is
made up
of the single city block occupied by the
thomas a edison
career and technical education high
school a single lap of which runs to a
grand total
of 883 metres for any
non-savants watching that means
participants must run around
the same unremarkable city block
a meniscal cartilage melting 5649
times in order to
the race and what does the almost
certainly clinically insane human being
who wins such a race take home as his
reward
a big fat check a small pile of diamonds
the secret to eternal life and the
signed first edition of
old tractors and the men who love them
yes that's a real book
no it's even worse
winners of the longest foot race ever
conceived by mankind
are usually awarded a t-shirt
or sometimes a dvd i'm not even kidding
if all this seems too bad to be true
then believe it or not you're actually
kind of getting it
because that's exactly the point
the key to this whole sadomasochistic
nightmare
is the self-transcendence part
of the race's name this race exists
for the sole purpose of pushing those
brave enough to compete in it
to the very limits of what a human being
is capable of both
physically and mentally the almost
comical distance the strict time limit
the lack of sleep
the utter trudging monotony of running
around
the same featureless city block over and
over again
day after day week after week
it's all designed to help competitors
transcend
what they recognize as their own
limits many runners make use of
meditation to overcome the mental
and physical hardships of the race and
out-of-body experiences are not uncommon
and as insanely challenging as this race
undoubtedly is
many competitors come back again year
after year
eager for another dose of mental and
physical
torture record holder asperahanol alto
who we heard about earlier has completed
this most ridiculous of races
15 times winning on nine occasions
that means in total he's run some
46 000 miles around
thomas a edison high school in jamaica
new york the equivalent of running twice
around the world i can only imagine the
students must be sick of the sight of
him
so the next time you're coming to the
end of your evening run
puffing and panting but feeling pretty
bloody proud of yourself
for knocking out a respectable five
miles
without puking up just think only
another 620 more of those
and you'll have completed the world's
longest
foot race thank you for watching
you can now pre-order my brand new book
sticker flag in it
on amazon the link is in the description
thank you